The thing about Hawaii is that before you go all anybody will say to you is, it's paradise. This is literally the word that people use. You tell a friend, I'm going to Hawaii, and then it's like you watch the word enter their brain. And the sensate thinking part of them goes away, and their eyes start to glaze. And then, as if in a dream, like a scene from The Manchurian Candidate, they say the word. It's paradise.
关于夏威夷，有一点是当你出发前，所有人只会对你说一句话：“那是天堂。”这真的是人们用的词。你告诉朋友你要去夏威夷，然后就像看着这个词进入了他们的脑海。他们感性思考的那部分消失了，眼神开始变得空洞。接着，仿佛在梦中，就像《满洲候选人》里的场景，他们说出了那个词：“那是天堂。”
From WBEZ Chicago, it's This American Life. I'm Ira Glass. Each week, of course, we choose a theme and invite a variety of writers and performers to tackle that team. Today's program, Nightmare Vacations, stories by Sandra Tsing Loh and David Sedaris and this question, if an American family can't get along in paradise, what hope is there?
这里是来自芝加哥WBEZ电台的《美国生活》，我是艾拉·格拉斯。每周，我们都会选择一个主题，并邀请各路作家和表演者来诠释这个主题。今天的节目是“噩梦假期”，故事由桑德拉·清·罗和戴维·塞达里斯讲述，同时也提出了这样一个问题：如果一个美国家庭在天堂里都相处不来，那还有什么希望呢？
So my sisters and nephews fly in from California. My parents fly in from the east coast. I take an early-morning plane from O'Hare. I went mainly because I wanted to spend some time with my parents. My dad was just out of the hospital. He'd had emergency surgery, nearly died. And I wanted to hang out with them, try to get along better, feel closer, which, in my family, as in many, is not so easy.
于是，我的姐妹和侄子们从加州飞来。我的父母从东海岸飞来。我搭乘芝加哥奥黑尔机场清晨的航班出发。我去的目的主要是想多花点时间陪伴父母。我父亲刚出院，他动了紧急手术，差点没命。我想陪陪他们，试着相处得更好，感觉更亲近，但在我的家庭里，像许多家庭一样，这并不容易。
I brought the pictures of my trip to show you. This one, this is the condo we stayed in. You can see palm trees through the windows. That's my sister Karen on the couch with a Diet Coke. Good Morning America, which I view as the clattering, vapid noise of Satan, is on the television. But that's what my parents like, and I wanted to do what they wanted to do. My parents' Hawaii was not a romantic place of ramshackle bungalows and beaches lit by torchlight. In fact, it was a suburban-looking condo with overstuffed pastel furniture and pastel hotel art prints framed on the wall in a timeshare community with tennis courts and easy parking and a mall and a grocery store. In short, this was the least exotic possible setting.
我把旅行的照片带来了给你们看。这一张，是我们住的公寓。你可以透过窗户看到棕榈树。那是我的姐姐凯伦，正瘫在沙发上喝健怡可乐。电视里放着《早安美国》，我把它视为撒旦发出的嘈杂、乏味的噪音。但那是父母喜欢的节目，我想做他们想做的事。我父母的夏威夷不是那种有着破旧平房和火把照亮沙滩的浪漫之地。事实上，那是一个有着塞满廉价家具、墙上挂着劣质酒店装饰画的郊区公寓，位于一个拥有网球场、停车方便、附近还有商场和杂货店的分时度假村里。总之，这是最缺乏异国情调的地方。
But when we arrived, my mom got out of the car, looked around the parking lot at the neatly trimmed lawns, and she said the word. Paradise.
但当我们到达时，母亲下了车，环顾停车场里修剪整齐的草坪，她说出了那个词：天堂。
This picture, this is my dad making cereal in the condo. My parents brought their favorite breakfast cereals with them, 10,000 miles to Hawaii. They like the familiar comforts of home, like many people do. In fact, in all sorts of stressful situations-- I hadn't actually quite put this together. I realized on this trip that in all sorts of stressful situations, what my parents do is that they make themselves comfortable by focusing on creating a comfortable, personal space.
这张照片，是我父亲在公寓里准备麦片。父母把他们最爱的早餐麦片从一万英里外带到了夏威夷。像许多人一样，他们喜欢家里的那种熟悉感。事实上，在各种压力情境下——我之前没怎么意识到这一点。这次旅行我发现，在各种压力情境下，父母处理问题的方式就是通过专注于营造一个舒适、私人的空间来让自己感到舒心。
When my sisters and I moved away to college, my parents comforted themselves by building a new house. When my mom got breast cancer five years ago, they decided to start a major rehab on the house. And in Hawaii, with the stress of having to deal with the children and the grandchildren, they spent a lot of time obsessing on the condo and what they saw as its many shortcomings. The sliding glass doors weren't the heavy, nice kind, my mom thought. The bathrooms' tiles and floors didn't have the quality that my mother would prefer. And rather than spend more time with their family, which was the point of the whole vacation, she would vanish for hours at the time. She would vanish for the whole afternoon. It'd be like, mom, where would she be? And she would have been out, checking out other condos and hotel accommodations, comparing.
当我和姐妹们离家上大学时，父母通过盖新房子来安慰自己。五年前母亲得乳腺癌时，他们决定对房子进行大规模装修。而在夏威夷，面对还要照顾孩子和孙辈的压力，他们花了大量时间纠结于公寓的种种缺陷。母亲认为，推拉门不是那种厚实耐用的。浴室的瓷砖和地板也没有达到她想要的品质。她没有花更多时间陪伴家人——而这才是度假的初衷，反而经常消失几个小时。她会整个下午都不见踪影。大家会问：“妈去哪了？”原来她一直在外面看别的公寓和酒店住宿，进行比较。
Let me see what else I got here. This is me snorkeling. At one point I talked everybody into renting snorkeling equipment. And we all went to one of these coves where they say it's really nice snorkeling. And when we got there, I could not get anybody to come in the water with me.
让我看看还有什么。这是我在浮潜。有一次，我劝服了所有人去租浮潜设备。我们都去了据说浮潜非常棒的海湾之一。但当我们到了那里，我却没法让任何人跟我下水。
It turned out that none of the things that you would expect that people would actually want to do in Hawaii were things that my parents, especially, were willing to do. They don't snorkel or swim. They don't like the ocean or the sun. They won't go to look at volcanoes. They don't want to see hula dancers. They don't want to drink fruity tropical drinks with umbrellas in them. My sisters and I, we couldn't even talk them into staying up late and playing cards with us.
事实证明，那些你预期人们在夏威夷会去做的事，我的父母尤其不愿意参与。他们不浮潜也不游泳。他们不喜欢海洋或阳光。他们不想去看火山。他们不想看草裙舞。他们不想喝带小伞的水果热带饮料。我和姐妹们甚至无法劝他们熬夜和我们打牌。
It begs the question, the central problem, the problem of the family vacation, what can people do that will make them feel closer? The activities offered by Hawaii seem so puny in comparison to the mountain that the average family presents.
这就引出了一个问题，家庭度假的核心矛盾：人们到底能做什么来拉近彼此的距离？与普通家庭所面临的巨大矛盾相比，夏威夷所提供的那些活动显得太微不足道了。
About 20 minutes after this picture was taken, I got out of the water, and we all kind of went our separate ways for the day. My mom went off to look at condos again. And I just did not want to go look at condos. Me, I did not believe that finding a place with heavier sliding glass doors and nicer towels in the bathroom was going to bring us any closer as a family. But it's not like I had any better ideas about how to get close.
这张照片拍完大约20分钟后，我从水里出来，我们那天各自分开了。母亲又去逛公寓了。我真的一点也不想去看公寓。对我来说，我不相信找到一个有更厚实推拉门、浴室有更好毛巾的住处，就能让我们家庭关系更亲密。但我也没什么拉近关系的好办法。
C.S. Lewis once wrote-- and I don't know if this is original to him, but anyway, it's in one of his books-- that there's no such thing as a heaven or hell. He says what happens after you die is that you simply continue to be the person who you are but for eternity. So you become more and more like yourself forever. And for some people, that's heaven. And for others, it's hell. I bring this up because I think paradise shares this quality with the afterlife. For some people, a vacation in paradise is paradise. But for others of us, it's much more difficult.
C.S.路易斯曾经写道——我不知道这是否是他原创的，但总之出现在他的一本书里——天堂或地狱并不存在。他说，死后发生的事情是你只是继续做你自己，但那是永恒的。所以你永远会越来越像你自己。对某些人来说，那是天堂。而对另一些人，那是地狱。我提到这点是因为我认为天堂（Paradise）和死后的世界有同样的性质。对某些人来说，在天堂度假就是天堂。但对我们其他人来说，这要困难得多。
[MUSIC - "IT'S NICE TO GO TRAV'LING" BY FRANK SINATRA]
[音乐 - 弗兰克·辛纳屈的《It's Nice to Go Trav'ling》]
Act Two.
第二幕。
My mother was an optimist. No, I mean really an optimist. This was a woman who, in 1969, planned a family summer vacation to Ethiopia.
我母亲是个乐观主义者。不，我是说真的很乐观。就是这样一个女人，在1969年计划了一场全家去埃塞俄比亚的暑假旅行。
Sandra Tsing Loh is a writer, performer, and composer. She's a columnist for Buzz Magazine in Los Angeles. This story is from her one-woman show Aliens in America, which is largely about her mother and her father.
桑德拉·清·罗是一位作家、表演者和作曲家。她是洛杉矶《Buzz》杂志的专栏作家。这个故事出自她的个人秀《美国的异类》，主要讲述了她的母亲和父亲。
In all fairness, Ethiopia was not her first choice. Given her druthers, she would have hopped on a luxury ocean liner to Hawaii while young men in tight pants served her peach schnapps on a silver tray. "Peach schnapps, it is the most elegant drink," she used to tell us girls. My mother stood 5'11", a fast-talking German brunette given to wearing bright red lipstick, big amber beads, polka dot dresses. My sister, Kaitlin, and I thought she was the most elegant person we'd ever seen. Of course, we were ages nine and six.
平心而论，埃塞俄比亚并不是她的首选。如果由她自己选择，她会跳上一艘豪华远洋客轮去夏威夷，让穿着紧身裤的年轻小伙在银盘上给她端上桃子甜酒。“桃子甜酒，这是最优雅的饮料，”她过去常对我们女孩说。母亲身高1米8，是一个说话语速极快、爱涂亮红色口红、戴着硕大琥珀珠子、喜欢波点连衣裙的德国棕发女性。我和姐姐凯特琳觉得她是我们见过最优雅的人。当然，那时候我们才六岁和九岁。
"Peach schnapps, we used to drink it all the time in Danzig before the war, when your mother and Tante Thea used to waltz to Strauss's Blue Danube, thank you very much, at the glittering ballroom in Sopot, built right over the sea, Mit Rosen Gardenin. And of course, you know your mother's dance card was saw from empty in those days. There was Hans Heinlich, Karl Obst, Dieter Fischer-Kucher."
“桃子甜酒，战前我们在但泽的时候常喝，那时你母亲和西娅姨妈经常在海边盖起的那座金碧辉煌的索波特舞厅，伴着施特劳斯的《蓝色多瑙河》跳华尔兹，谢谢啦。当然，你知道你母亲当年的舞伴名单从未空缺。什么汉斯·海因里希、卡尔·奥布斯特、迪特尔·费舍尔-库彻等等。”
My mother was a nonstop talker. She would not stop talking. That's why she was so sure her Hawaii pitch would work. "Palm trees, pineapples. [SINGING] Bali Hai. Bali Hai, Bali Hai, Bali Hai."
母亲是个停不下来的话痨。她根本停不下来。这就是为什么她那么确信她关于夏威夷的推销会奏效。“棕榈树，菠萝。[唱歌] 巴厘海。巴厘海，巴厘海。”
But my father never took to the idea of spending money for the sole purpose of fun. Vacations, birthdays, swimming lessons, Christmas-- these were concepts that didn't really work for him. "It is not that I do not like to spend money," he'd say. "Oh, no. Spend, spend, spend. That's just all I do. It is just that I do not like to throw it away on nothing." Hawaii, of course, was nothing, a horror of sunny beaches, fruity drinks, laughing, happy people. "Why would we want to go there? Where is the educational value?"
但我父亲从不接受为了娱乐而花钱这个念头。度假、生日、游泳课、圣诞节——这些概念对他来说根本行不通。“不是说我不喜欢花钱，”他说，“噢，不。花钱、花钱、花钱，这我当然会。只是我不喜欢把钱浪费在虚无缥缈的事上。”夏威夷当然就是“虚无”的代名词，全是阳光沙滩、水果饮料、欢笑、快乐的人的噩梦。“我们为什么要在那儿？有什么教育意义吗？”
My father, by contrast, was fascinated with Uruguay. Why? He had a friend there we could stay with for free. But it was more than that. "The people of Uruguay are very, very sensible and hardworking. The agrarian farm workers face a fascinating challenge with the combines and the technological hurdles that they--" blah, blah, blah, blah, blah.
相比之下，我父亲对乌拉圭很着迷。为什么？因为他在那儿有个朋友，我们可以免费住在他家。但这不仅仅是因为钱。“乌拉圭的人们非常、非常务实且勤劳。那些农业工人在联合收割机和技术障碍面前面临着迷人的挑战，他们……”巴拉巴拉一大堆。
You might wonder how such opposite people as my parents got together in the first place. I blame it on Buick. When my mother first saw my father in the mid '50s, he was sitting behind the wheel of a shiny new '56 Buick. I guess a man looks better than he ought in a Buick, especially when it's surrounded by southern California in the '50s, a palm-fringed, swimming-pool-dotted utopia lit by a sun so bright, you actually start to hallucinate. You believe you are in fact quite similar to a person. After all, one, both of you are new immigrants, recently escaped from bad circumstances in your home countries. My father was orphaned by age 12 in Shanghai, lived in poverty. My mother went through World War II, ran from soldiers, heard bombs drop around her.
你可能会好奇，像我父母这样截然不同的人当初是怎么走到一起的。我怪罪于别克车。我母亲在50年代中期第一次见到我父亲时，他正坐在那一辆崭新的56年款别克车驾驶座上。我想一个男人在别克车里看起来会比他本人帅得多，尤其是在50年代的南加州，那片被棕榈树环绕、点缀着游泳池、被明亮的太阳照耀得仿佛产生幻觉的乌托邦里。你会相信你和某人真的很合拍。毕竟，你们俩都是新移民，最近刚从各自国家的糟糕境遇中逃离。我父亲12岁在上海成了孤儿，过着穷苦日子。我母亲经历了第二次世界大战，四处躲避士兵，听着炸弹在身边爆炸。
Of course, my mother hated stories of such grim, Zolaesque realism. Her favorite after-dinner stories were either goofy or schmaltzy, ending hopefully with a glass of peach schnapps and a singalong of some kind. When American friends at dinner parties asked her about hardship in Danzig, World War II, Polish occupation, she'd cut them off at the path. "But enough of me. We are all of us travelers, nicht wahr? Foreign people in a foreign land. And we all of us miss home. Let us sing. [SINGING] Edelweiss, Edelweiss, you look happy to see me."
当然，母亲讨厌那些阴郁的、左拉式的现实主义故事。她最喜欢的晚餐故事要么滑稽，要么煽情，结局通常是喝一杯桃子甜酒，唱一首什么歌。当美国朋友在晚宴上问她关于但泽的艰辛、二战、波兰占领等经历时，她总是会岔开话题。“但别提我了。我们都是旅行者，不是吗？在他乡的异国人。我们都想家。来唱歌吧。[唱歌] 雪绒花，雪绒花，看到我你显得很高兴。”
Similarity number two between my parents, nothing, except, I guess, that both had come to America, a place where miserable yesterdays could be traded in for joyous visions of tomorrow. And why not? It was the '60s, a great time for America. Jackie O was in the White House. Apollo rockets were in the sky. The future was made flesh at eye-popping World's Fairs featuring whizzing monorails above. Below, pavilions of happy, dancing third-world people joining hands and singing, [SINGING] "It's a small world after all. It's a small world after all."
父母之间的第二个共同点，除了都是移民到美国这个能把痛苦的昨天换成欢乐的明天的愿景的地方之外，什么都没有。为什么不呢？那是60年代，美国的黄金时代。杰奎琳·肯尼迪在白宫。阿波罗火箭在天空中。未来在引人注目的世博会上展现，头顶是飞驰的单轨列车。下面，来自第三世界的人们手拉手跳着舞，唱着：“这是一个小世界，毕竟，这是一个小世界。”
So what if my parents had nothing in common. Never mind. My mother would make this work. In 1969, after many disagreements, she had learned to be crafty. She dropped the idea of Hawaii or Florida or Disneyland. All she was suggesting was a four-day trip to Massawa, Pearl of the Red Sea, which lay on a little known, remote part of Ethiopia. It was the last adventure my parents would ever agree on.
所以，如果父母没有共同点又怎样？没关系。母亲会想办法搞定的。1969年，在多次争吵后，她学会了精明。她放弃了夏威夷、佛罗里达或迪士尼的想法。她建议的是一次为期四天的马萨瓦之旅——红海明珠，坐落在埃塞俄比亚一个鲜为人知的遥远地带。这是父母唯一达成共识的一次冒险。
"Ethiopia?" My father, of course, had been immediately interested. And why not? Ethiopia was notoriously backward, wretched poor. At that time, too, they were recovering from some sort of bloody civil war, leaving its countryside bleak, its peoples desperate. No one in the world would want to go on vacation in Ethiopia, which my father saw could be turned to our advantage. "After all," my father asked, "if no one else is going, think how far the American dollar will go." "He thinks a vacation should cost one American dollar," Kaitlin and I plead with my mom. "He's cheap and mean." We were onto him, even them. "He just doesn't want us to have any fun. Please, Mom. We don't want to go to Ethiopia."
“埃塞俄比亚？”父亲当然立刻就感兴趣了。为什么不呢？埃塞俄比亚当时在国际上出了名的落后、极度贫穷。那时他们刚从一场血腥内战中恢复，农村地区萧条，人民生活窘迫。世界上没人会想去埃塞俄比亚度假，父亲认为这正好可以利用。“毕竟，”父亲问道，“如果没别人去，想想美金在那里能花多久。”“他觉得度假应该只花一美元，”凯特琳和我求母亲。“他太吝啬太刻薄了。我们看穿他了。他就是不想让我们玩。求你了，妈妈。我们不想去埃塞俄比亚。”
"Ethiopia?" she asked. "Where is that? Oh, you mean E-th-o-p-ia!" She sang it as though it were Rogers and Hammerstein musical, like "Oklahoma." "E-th-o-p-ia! You mean home of the fabulous little town of Massawa, Pearl of the Red Sea, with its beautiful beaches and luxurious resort hotel with its glittering ballroom built right over the sea, Mit Rosen Gardenin, just like in Sopot?" "Really?" we asked. "Naturilich! It's all right here in my kleine deutsche Reisebuch. Father does not know it yet. He'll probably be quite angry. But once we get there, we will run away from your father and swim on the beach."
“埃塞俄比亚？”她问道，“那是什么地方？噢，你是说埃-塞-俄-比-亚！”她唱起来仿佛那是罗杰斯和汉默斯坦的音乐剧，像《俄克拉荷马》一样。“埃-塞-俄-比-亚！你是说红海明珠马萨瓦小镇的故乡，有美丽的沙滩，还有那种建在海上的豪华度假村，带花园的，就像索波特那样？”“真的吗？”我们问。“当然！都在我的德语旅游小书里。父亲还不知道。他大概会很生气。但一旦到了那儿，我们就背着父亲去海滩游泳。”
"Swim on the beach" was the kind of word my mother would use to describe anything that was too wonderful to be possible and therefore would never come to pass. Swim on the beach with the Pearl of the Red Sea. Who knew?
“海滩游泳”是母亲用来形容任何过于美好以至于不可能发生的事情的词。去红海明珠的海滩游泳，谁知道呢？
Air Ethiopia was not a good airline. A plunging, four-hour ride on a shuttering gray plane brought us to a town with a suspiciously gay name of Lalibella. "Lalibella!" my mother exclaimed in mock dismay as its airport, a manure field, rose up to meet us. The hotel Lalibella seemed made entirely of peat, and peat which had taken its kicks and beatings from the desert wind for a long time. Thick woven carpets with ominous symbols hung everywhere, exuding a faint hay smell. Kaitlin and I were given sour glasses of lemonade to drink as we perched on the family suitcases, watching scrawny sheep graze outside a big picture window. All at once, the sheep screamed and scattered. A man in a galabia was running after them with an ax.
埃塞俄比亚航空不是一家好航空公司。在一架颠簸、老旧的灰色飞机上经历了四小时的煎熬后，我们降落在一个名字听起来有些讽刺的拉利贝拉镇。“拉利贝拉！”母亲惊呼道，因为迎接我们的机场就是一个粪场。拉利贝拉酒店似乎完全是用泥炭做的，那种长期忍受沙漠风沙吹打的泥炭。厚重的织物挂毯上印着不祥的符号，散发着一股淡淡的干草味。凯特琳和我坐在行李箱上，喝着酸涩的柠檬水，看着瘦骨嶙峋的羊在窗外吃草。突然，羊群尖叫着四散奔逃，一个穿着长袍的男人正挥舞着斧头追赶它们。
I turned from this weird spectacle to contemplate yet another. There stood my mother with four German tourists, large and blond and gleaming in their sweat-streaked khaki, expensive cameras and voluptuous leather travel bags draped around them like fresh kill. Apparently there was no place in Africa so miserable some German tourist did not want to see it. [SPEAKING GERMAN] my mother cried out, raising her hands imploringly, a beat. And then all five adult fell into a group hug. There was laughter, sighing, a rapid German exchange. [SPEAKING GERMAN] Danzig?" was the startled query. Emphatic nodding. "Ach ja. Ach ja." So they all originally hailed from my mother's hometown. Photos were coming out of purses and bags now, chocolates, maps of where they had gone, of where they were going. And now here's where the Massawa, Pearl of the Red Sea, magic really clicked in. By incredible coincidence, Ilsa, Franz-Joseph, and the fat couple were headed too to Massawa, Pearl of the Red Sea. It would be a party. Maybe Kaitlin and I would even get to swim on the beach.
我从这一怪诞场景转向观察另一个。那里站着母亲和四个德国游客，男人们又高又壮，穿着被汗水浸透的卡其色衣服，脖子上挂着昂贵的相机，身上缠着奢华的皮质旅行包，简直像是刚猎杀回来的战利品。显然，非洲没有哪个地方苦到连德国游客都不想去看一眼。[德语] 母亲大叫着，举起双手恳求。接着，五个大人拥抱在一起。欢笑声、叹息声，快速的德语交流。“[德语] 但泽？”一个吃惊的询问。肯定的点头。“啊，是的。啊，是的。”原来他们都来自母亲的家乡。照片从钱包里拿出来，还有巧克力、地图，标示着他们去过的地方和即将去的地方。这时，红海明珠马萨瓦的魔力真的显现了。不可思议的是，伊尔莎、弗朗茨-约瑟夫和那对胖夫妇也要去马萨瓦。这下成了一个派对。也许凯特琳和我也能去海滩游泳了。
With a wave of my mother's hand, the whole group sat down to a surprisingly festive Ethiopian dinner of bread and peas and potatoes and, of course, fresh mutton that Kaitlin and I had watched nibble its last blades of grass just hours earlier. The adult buzz was growing to a roar. "Hoohoo-hoo-hoo!" There was much slapping of thighs and lifting of glasses. Even my father was having fun. Franz-Joseph had just announced that he was picking up the dinner tab. "Du ferrukten Deutschen," my father guffawed in his terrible German, reaching over and goosing Ilsa on the rear. She was big-hearted enough to laugh it off. I think the Germans were amused by my Chinese father, as though he were a small attack dog.
随着母亲一挥手，整个团队坐下来吃了一顿意想不到的埃塞俄比亚盛宴，有面包、豌豆、土豆，当然还有新鲜的羊肉——就在几小时前，凯特琳和我还看着它们在吃草。大人们的喧闹声越来越大。“嚯嚯嚯！”一阵拍大腿和举杯的声音。连父亲也玩得很开心。弗朗茨-约瑟夫宣布他要买单。“你这疯狂的德国佬，”父亲用蹩脚的德语大笑着，凑过去捏了伊尔莎的后臀一把。她倒是大度，只是一笑了之。我想德国人被我这个中国父亲逗乐了，仿佛他是一只小小的看门狗。
But even as they were drinking, my mother told us later, she knew that something was kaput. Because while the Deutschen were indeed headed to Massawa, they were planning to fly. My father, of course, had just gotten tickets for the bus. Although, back at the Addis Ababa Airport, there had been some question of safety about the bus, never quite explained. "Please," one travel official in a shabby blue suit had plead with my parents. "You are wealthy Americans. I beg of you. The people of the bus, they are not good." But my father stood firm. Why ride in a plane for an hour when you could sit on a bus for nine and save almost $30 for four people? "Besides," he insisted, "we are not stupid tourists. We will go the way the natives go. It will be so much more educational."
但正如母亲后来告诉我们的，虽然大人们在喝酒，她却知道事情要糟。因为德国人虽然确实要去马萨瓦，但他们计划坐飞机。而父亲当然刚刚买了汽车票。虽然在亚的斯亚贝巴机场时，关于那辆巴士的安全性曾有一些未解释的疑问。“求求你们，”一位身穿破旧蓝色制服的旅游官员恳求我父母，“你们是有钱的美国人。我求求你们。坐那辆巴士的人，不太好。”但父亲坚持己见。为什么坐一小时飞机，当你可以坐九小时巴士还能省下近30美元？“况且，”他坚持道，“我们又不是愚蠢的游客。我们要走当地人的路。这更有教育意义。”
But, of course, our new German friends would not buy that. My mother was stuck, so she fudged the truth just a little. "But have you heard about the fabulous bus?" she asked the group over that festive Ethiopian dinner. She herself looked fabulous that night, her crisp, dark hair set off by a fire-engine red dress and big, amber beads. "The scenery is absolutely stunning. You will miss it all by plane. Everyone takes the bus. It is what is done. Perhaps a bit rustic, but sehr gemutlich in its own way. It is the one place where adventure und economy meet. Please, my friends, you must take the bus with us. Please. Life is too short, too short. Because we are, all of us, travelers, nicht wahr? Foreign people in a foreign land." There was a hush, then an explosion of hugging and weeping and something being spilled.
但当然，我们新的德国朋友不会听这套。母亲被困住了，所以她稍微篡改了事实。“但是你们听说了那辆绝妙的巴士吗？”她在节日般的晚餐中问大家。那一晚她看起来光彩照人，蓬松的深色头发，火红的裙子配着硕大的琥珀珠子。“景色绝对令人惊叹。坐飞机全错过了。大家都会选巴士。这才是正事。也许有点简陋，但有它独特的温馨。这是冒险和经济实惠的结合点。求求你们，朋友们，一定要跟我们坐巴士。求求你们。生命太短了。因为我们都是旅行者，不是吗？在他乡的异国人。”一阵沉默，接着是一阵拥抱、哭泣和打翻杯子的混乱。
So the mood is bright, if somewhat hung over, the next morning when we all reconnoiter at the bus station, yet another manure field. "Guten morgen!" my mother calls out. "Guten morgen!" the Germans cry back. They supervises as a small Ethiopian hefts their fabulous leather luggage on top of the bus, tying it all down with skeins of twine. The many Ethiopian peasants, the women in black muslin and the men in work shirts and wrinkled corduroys, pretty much ignore us, busy lifting their own chicken coops and lentil baskets.
第二天早上，当我们都在巴士站重聚时，气氛很热烈，尽管都有点宿醉。“早安！”母亲喊道。“早安！”德国人回应。他们监督着一个埃塞俄比亚小伙子把他们昂贵的行李箱装上车顶，用麻绳捆好。许多埃塞俄比亚平民，穿着黑色薄纱的女人们和穿着工装裤的男人们，几乎忽略了我们，忙着搬运他们自己的鸡笼和扁豆篮子。
"A small detail," as my mother liked to put it later when she'd retell the story-- "a small detail" is that there's not one but two buses heading out towards Massawa this day. We and the Germans are all assigned to the first bus. Our family is further subdivided into three seats together at the front, ours, and one way, way at the back, among the chicken coops, my father's. Good. But here's the wrinkle. Our seats are right over the wheel. The floor rises in a hump under our feet. We can't stretch our legs out. For nine hours. And, as I've told you, my mother is 5'11".
“一个小细节，”母亲后来重述这个故事时喜欢这样说——“一个小细节”是那天开往马萨瓦的巴士不是一辆，而是两辆。我们和德国人都被分配到了第一辆。我们一家人被挤到了前面，而父亲则在最后，挤在鸡笼里。好极了。但问题在于，我们的座位正好在轮子上方。地板在我们脚下隆起一个包。我们九个小时都无法伸直双腿。而且，如我所说，母亲身高1米8。
But the bus officials seem oddly opposed to us changing our seats. Why? The first bus is full, and for some odd reason, they do not want to put us on the second. But my mother insists. "But we cannot sit there. We cannot. Mein Gott! It is intolerable. We are not animals." And then, in with the haymaker. "I will go to the American consulate." Bingo. Without a word, three of us are moved to the second bus, far from anyone we know.
但巴士官员似乎奇怪地反对我们换座。为什么？第一辆车满了，出于某种原因他们不想让我们去第二辆。但母亲坚持。“我们不能坐在那里。不行！天哪！这无法忍受。我们又不是牲口。”然后，她祭出了杀手锏。“我要去美国领事馆。”成了。话音刚落，我们三人被移到了第二辆车，远离了认识的任何人。
The buses navigate their way down treacherous mountains. The mountains are beautiful, if threatening in their jagged blueness. Occasionally a small peasant child in a soiled galabia runs by the side of the road, waving. His small shout fades off in the distance. "Ahhhhh!"
巴士在险峻的山路上穿行。山峦很美，尽管那参差的蓝色显得有些威胁感。偶尔，一个穿着脏旧长袍的小孩在路边跑过，挥着手。他的喊声在远方消失。“啊——！”
The road zigzags, zigzags. At the end of each hairpin turn is a lone white cross. I drop off to sleep.
公路蜿蜒曲折。每个发夹弯的尽头都立着一个孤独的白十字架。我昏昏欲睡。
Popping, like the sound of a truck backfiring, jolts me awake. All around us, Ethiopian peasants are dropping to the floor. There are shouts. Then, all at once, like a congregation, the Ethiopians rise and file down the aisle, fingers laced on top of their heads. My mother does not say two words to us. She kneels swiftly. Her hands fly over our bags. She stuffs all of our family's passports and traveler's checks under Kaitlin's and my blouses, smoothing our waistbands to hold them in place.
一声类似卡车后燃的巨响把我惊醒。周围的埃塞俄比亚平民全都趴在地上。有叫喊声。然后，像礼拜一样，埃塞俄比亚人起身，排队走过过道，双手抱头。母亲没跟我们说两个字。她迅速跪下。她的手飞快地翻过我们的包，把所有的护照和旅行支票塞进我和凯特琳的衬衫里，抚平腰带把它们固定住。
"Are we there yet?" I ask. My mother claps her hand over my mouth and pushes me towards the door. When I get there, I see what the twin forces of adventure and economy have brought us to. Not a pavilion of happy, dancing people, but Eritrean terrorists clad in military fatigues, firing machine guns randomly into the air. Ahead of us, an Ethiopian peasant woman's cheap black purse is cut from her arm.
“到了吗？”我问。母亲一把捂住我的嘴，把我推向门口。当我走出去时，我看到了冒险和经济实惠带来的结果。不是什么快乐跳舞的亭子，而是身穿军装的厄立特里亚恐怖分子，正乱枪向天射击。在我们前面，一个埃塞俄比亚妇女的便宜黑色钱包被从手臂上割了下来。
Obedient as Ethiopian sheep, we file down the stairs and form ourselves into what appears, sickeningly, to be firing squad formation. All around us is the blankness of the Eritrean desert. Ahead of us, the road stretches out towards Massawa, Pearl of the Red Sea, pitted an empty. "Oh, God," I think. "Oh, God."
我们像埃塞俄比亚绵羊一样服从，走下楼梯，排成了看起来让人作呕的行刑队阵型。四周是一片虚无的厄立特里亚沙漠。前面，通往红海明珠马萨瓦的路显得坑坑洼洼、空空如也。“噢，上帝，”我想，“噢，上帝。”
Now I look up into the wide blue sky. The great blue depth is mesmerizing, oddly peaceful. "So, this is it," I think, "the end of my life, right here." No more sour lemonade. No more hay smell. I will never grow up to be 20." We wait. But the bullets do not come.
现在我抬起头看向宽阔的蓝天。那深邃的蓝色让人着迷，出奇地平静。“就这样了，”我想，“生命的尽头，就在这里。没有酸柠檬水了。没有干草味了。我永远长不到20岁了。”我们等待着，但子弹没有落下来。
It gradually dawns on us that the terrorists' real interest is in the first bus, not the second. 50 yards up the road, Ilsa, Franz-Joseph, and the fat couple have become the center of attention. They stand helplessly in their sumptuous safari outfits, hands in the air. The leader shouts at them.
逐渐地，我们意识到恐怖分子的目标是第一辆车，而不是我们这辆。前方50码处，伊尔莎、弗朗茨-约瑟夫和那对胖夫妇成了焦点。他们穿着奢华的狩猎装，无助地站在那里，高举双手。领头的人冲他们吼叫。
My eye slides down the line of first bus passengers. And there, towards the end, is my father. With a small body, dark coloring, and worn rag sweater, he actually kind of blends in. And I realize in that moment with a kind of savvy world traveler's instinct that my father will not be shot that day. And in some small way, I am glad. Franz-Joseph, Ilsa, and the fat couple, on the other hand, are being marched off towards the low brown hills as hostages.
我的视线扫过第一辆车的乘客。在那里，靠近末尾的地方，是我父亲。由于身材矮小、肤色深沉，穿着破旧的毛衣，他竟然融进了人群中。在那一瞬间，我有一种精明旅行者的直觉：父亲今天不会被枪杀。在某种程度上，我感到高兴。而弗朗茨-约瑟夫、伊尔莎和那对胖夫妇，则被押往低矮的棕色山丘作为人质。
"Ethiopia!" my mother cries out. It is five years later. She is back in our dining room in southern California, finishing the Pearl of the Red Sea story for yet another group of mesmerized dinner guests. "But how?" someone asked. "But naturilich! The bus company set it all up. It was totally corrupt. They put all the foreigners on the first bus to make it easy. Had it not been for the wheel, the wheel, I and the putzenlinchins would've been marched off as hostages as well. Our Deutschen friends were released two weeks later, but their passports, cameras, traveler's checks, they never got back. At that point, they may had wished they'd flown, but then they would not have saved that $30. Who needed to see the Pearl of the Red Sea anyway? Not us. That night we dined on hot dogs und chocolate milk at the American military base in Massawa. We slept on metal beds. It was so elegant. Morgan fruh, we were chauffeured straight back to Lalibella via military convoy, which was fine with me, I said, as long as I don't have to sit over the wheel."
“埃塞俄比亚！”母亲大叫。那是五年后了。她在南加州的饭厅里，为又一群听得入迷的晚宴客人讲完红海明珠的故事。“但怎么会？”有人问。“但当然！巴士公司早就设计好的。完全腐败。他们把所有外国人都放在第一辆车上。要不是那个轮子，我早就和那些德国朋友一起被押为人质了。我们的德国朋友两周后被释放了，但护照、相机、支票都没拿回来。到那时，他们可能希望自己坐了飞机，但那样就省不了那30美元了。谁需要看红海明珠呢？反正不是我们。那天晚上我们在马萨瓦的美军基地吃了热狗和巧克力牛奶。睡的是铁架床。真是优雅。第二天清晨，我们被军事护卫车队直接送回了拉利贝拉，我对此没意见，只要不用再坐在那个轮子上面就行。”
Everyone applauds and laughs, and so do I, wanting the story to go on and on. But as the years go by, my mother gets more and more tired of telling it because the Ethiopian vacation comes to be the story of her marriage, a compromise between two opposites that can never be made to work. Eventually my parents spend all their time alone screaming and fighting. And then they stop talking at all, live together in silence, two strangers under one roof.
大家鼓掌欢笑，我也笑了，希望故事永无止境。但随着岁月流逝，母亲变得越来越厌倦讲述这个故事，因为埃塞俄比亚假期成了她婚姻的缩影，一种永远无法调和的对立妥协。最终，父母把所有时间都用来争吵。后来他们干脆停止说话，住在一个屋檐下却形同陌路。
What my mother will do sometimes after a dinner party is slip into the garage. Still in her amber beads and fire-engine red dress, she sits alone in my father's '56 Buick, puts the radio on, smokes a cigarette. Because the true mirage turns out to be not the Pearl of the Red Sea but that Buick. When my mother had first seen it on that magical day in the '50s, it was the car of a true American, a man who had put his sorry past behind. But that Buick would turn out to be an anomaly in my father's life, a youthful extravagance from which he would never quite recover. As the years went by, it would make my father sick for anyone even to drive it, to waste money on gas.
晚宴结束后，母亲有时会溜进车库。她依然戴着琥珀珠子，穿着火红裙子，独自坐在父亲的56年款别克车里，打开收音机，抽一支烟。因为真正的海市蜃楼原来不是红海明珠，而是那辆别克。当母亲在50年代那个魔幻的日子第一次见到它时，它是真正美国人的座驾，一个把悲惨过去抛在脑后的男人的象征。但那辆别克最终成了父亲生活中的异数，一次他永远没法从中走出来的年轻挥霍。多年后，只要有人想开它或浪费汽油钱，他就会感到痛苦。
So, while my mother left her World War II behind, he could not forget his Shanghai. He has brought it with him, and this is where they live, not in America but in his Shanghai. So in his home, it is she who remains the perpetual traveller, a foreign person always in a foreign land.
所以，当母亲把二战抛在身后时，他却无法忘记他的上海。他把它带在了身上，而这就是他们生活的地方，不是在美国，而是在他的上海。所以在这个家里，只有她成了永久的旅行者，一个永远在他乡的异国人。
Sandra Tsing Loh is the author of the book Depth Takes a Holiday. Coming up, David Sedaris travels without his family. In a minute, when our program continues.
桑德拉·清·罗是《深度度假》的作者。接下来，戴维·塞达里斯将讲述他不带家人旅行的故事。稍后，我们的节目继续。
It's This American Life. I'm Ira Glass. Each week on our program we choose a topic, bring you stories from a variety of writers and performers. Today's show, Vacations. We've arrived at Act Three. While Sandra Tsing Loh's story represents a kind of a limit case, the ultimate scenario of a nightmare family vacation, traveling without your family has its own little problems. David Sedaris has this story about awakening to all the possibilities of just hitting the road alone. David is the author of the book Barrel Fever, a sometimes commentator on NPR'S Morning Edition, and a frequent contributor to This American Life.
这里是《美国生活》，我是艾拉·格拉斯。每周我们选择一个主题，带来各路作家的故事。今天的节目是“假期”。我们进入了第三幕。虽然桑德拉的故事代表了一种极限案例，即噩梦级家庭度假的终极场景，但独自旅行也有它自己的小麻烦。戴维·塞达里斯讲述了他独自上路后发现的无限可能性。戴维是《木桶热》的作者，也是NPR《早间版》的常客和《美国生活》的常驻撰稿人。
It started innocently enough the year I began the ninth grade and attended an all-day Planet of the Apes marathon at a budget theater a mile or so from my parents' house. I had seen the original movie nine times, waiting always for Vera to ask, "What will he find out there in the forbidden zone, Dr. Zaius?" followed by Charlton Heston's heartfelt, "Damn you! Damn you all to hell!" when he discovers he's been on his home planet throughout the course of the entire movie.
一切始于九年级那年，我在父母家附近的一家低价电影院看了一场全天的《人猿星球》马拉松。那部原版电影我已经看了九遍，总是在等待薇拉问出那句：“他在禁区外会发现什么，扎伊厄斯博士？”接着是查尔顿·赫斯顿发现自己整部电影其实都在自己的家乡行星上时，那句发自肺腑的：“该死！你们都该下地狱！”
I had entered the theater on a bright, humid morning, but when I came out, dazed and candy-bloated, it was dark and raining. I thought of calling for a ride, but my mother was off enduring my older sister's flute recital. That left my father, and he was out of the question. "I'll be there in 10 minutes," he'd say. In the background, I would hear nothing, which meant he was holed up in his bedroom watching a golf tournament on TV.
那天早晨，我是伴着明媚潮湿的阳光走进影院的，但当我头晕脑胀、吃撑了糖果出来时，天已经黑了，还在下雨。我想过叫人接，但母亲正忙着参加姐姐的长笛演奏会。父亲没戏。“我十分钟就到，”他会说。背景里我什么也听不见，这意味着他正缩在卧室看高尔夫锦标赛。
Golf involved hours of dead time interrupted every so often by the announcer, who would whisper, "Butler is obviously thinking about last week's disastrous seventh hole at Glistening Sands." I'd call back an hour later, and my father would answer, saying, "I'm on my way out the door right this minute. Jesus, give me a second, will you?" On the television, one of the pros would pace the fairway, hitching up his lime-green slacks. "It's bogey or nothing if Snead wants to come in at par 72." You could outgrow your clothing waiting for my father to pick you up.
高尔夫总是伴随着几小时的死寂，偶尔被播音员低语打断：“巴特勒显然在回想上周在闪耀沙地第七洞的那场灾难。”我一小时后再打过去，父亲会回答：“我正要出门呢。天哪，给我一秒钟好吗？”电视里，一位职业选手正拖着他那条酸橙绿的长裤走在球道上。“如果斯尼德想保住72杆，这一洞必须打出柏忌。”等父亲来接你，你的衣服都得穿小了。
I left the theater and held out my thumb. It was just that easy. My father was in the habit of picking up hitchhikers. We would be packed into the station wagon on our way to the pool or the grocery store, and he would pull over, instructing us to make room for company. It was exciting to have a stranger in the car. My father, his cocktail tinkling between his thighs, was always gracious but at the same time suspicious, behaving as though he were in on some big secret and could pinpoint the lies these people told. "OK, Rudy, I'll be happy to take you to your grandmother's house so you can pick up your laundry." [LAUGHS] He would shake his head and chuckle to himself, but the hitchhikers didn't seem to mind.
我离开影院，伸出了大拇指。就是这么简单。父亲有载搭车人的习惯。我们过去常挤在旅行车里去游泳或买菜，他会停下来，指挥我们给陌生人腾地方。车里有陌生人很令人兴奋。父亲在大腿间摇晃着鸡尾酒杯，总是彬彬有礼，但同时又疑神疑鬼，仿佛他掌握着什么惊天秘密，能识破这些人说的谎话。“好吧，鲁迪，很高兴带你去你奶奶家拿衣服。”[笑] 他会摇着头暗自偷笑，但搭车人似乎并不介意。
I noticed, though, that he only stopped for young people. We would spot some stooped and weathered man standing beside a beat-up suitcase and call out for my father to stop. "Dad, look," but he drove right on by as if they were painted cutouts advertising a restaurant named Tramp's or Hobo's.
不过我注意到，他只载年轻人。我们会看到路边站着满脸风霜的老人，行李箱破旧，于是求父亲停车。“爸，看，”但他直接开了过去，仿佛那是卖给“流浪汉餐厅”的装饰画。
I held out my thumb, figuring that someone like my father would pick me up, but instead it was an old woman, her helmet of hair protected by a plastic rain cap. She rolled down her window and shouted, "Damn you. Get your sorrowful butt into this car." She wore a pale blue uniform, the outfit issued to the cashiers at the local supermarket chain. "I got a grandson out there about your age, and if I ever caught him hitching a ride, I'd stick my foot so far up his butt, I'd lose my shoe. What do you think you're doing out there? Where are your people?"
我伸出拇指，以为会像父亲那样有人载我，结果停下的是个老太太，头发包在塑料雨帽里。她摇下车窗大喊：“该死。把你那可怜的屁股挪进车里。”她穿着那家当地超市收银员的淡蓝色制服。“我有个孙子跟你差不多大，如果让我看见他在搭车，我会一脚踢进他屁股深处让他连鞋都丢了。你在这儿干什么？你家里人呢？”
I told her that my father was a POW in Vietnam, and my mother, she's a long-haul truck driver on a run to Kansas City. "Right," the woman said, stubbing out her cigarette, "and I breast-feed baby camels in my backyard just for the freaking fun of it." She pulled up in front of my parents' house. "Truck driver my pretty pink keister. Now you get in that house, and you stay there before someone carves you up. You were lucky this time, but if I ever catch you out here again, I'll run you down just to spare you the misery."
我告诉她父亲是越南战俘，母亲是跑堪萨斯城的卡车司机。“好啊，”老太太掐灭烟头，“那我还在后院喂小骆驼纯粹是为了好玩呢。”她把车停在我父母家门口。“卡车司机，你这漂漂亮亮的粉色小笨蛋。现在给我滚进屋去，在被人剁碎前别出来。你这次走运了，但如果再让我抓到你，我直接把你碾死算了。”
I started hitchhiking on a regular basis. Aside from the convenience, I liked the fact that these people didn't know anything about me. I could reinvent myself every time I opened a car door, trying on whichever personality happened to suit my mood. Some people pulled up as if if they were expecting me hours ago, while others slowed down to study me before coming to a complete stop. There were black ministers and retired locksmiths, lifeguards, college students, and floor sanders, and they were usually alone. Raleigh wasn't that big of a town, and most people didn't mind going a mile or two out of their way.
我开始频繁搭车。除了方便，我喜欢这些人对我一无所知的事实。我每次打开车门都能重塑自己，尝试任何符合心情的人格。有些人停下来仿佛早就在等我，有些人减速观察我一番才完全停车。有黑人牧师、退休锁匠、救生员、大学生和地板磨光工，他们通常独自一人。罗利这个城市并不大，大多数人不介意绕一两英里。
I never hitchhiked beyond the city limits until I was sent off to college and met a girl named Ronnie. Her mother had died in the living room while confined to an iron lung, and her father had remarried twice within the last four years, dragging her through two sets of stepfamilies. Ronnie was tough and independent in a way I'd never known. She'd had a secret sleepover boyfriend at the age of 15 and was well-instructed in the arts of cigarette rolling, camping, breaking and entering, and hair care.
直到我离家去上大学并遇见罗尼，我才开始在城市边界外搭车。她母亲是在铁肺里去世的，父亲在四年内再婚两次，带着她经历了两个继母家庭。罗尼有一种我从未见过的强悍与独立。她15岁就有过秘密约会男友，精通卷烟、露营、入室盗窃和理发。
Our campus was isolated in the mountains of western North Carolina, far from anything one might label a point of interest, but Ronnie took charge, initiating hitchhiking trips to Asheville and Gatlinburg, to Nashville and Raleigh and Washington. At the end of the school year, I transferred to Kent State, and Ronnie packed off to San Francisco, where her brother arranged a job for her at a movie theater. I lasted a year in Ohio before deciding to join her.
校园位于北卡罗来纳州西部山区，远离任何被称为“景点”的地方，但罗尼掌管了大局，发起了去阿什维尔、加特林堡、纳什维尔、罗利和华盛顿的搭车旅行。学年结束时，我转学去了肯特州立大学，罗尼搬去了旧金山，她哥哥在那里给她安排了一份电影院的工作。我在俄亥俄州待了一年后决定去找她。
I'd never hitchhiked that far, much less alone. Allowing fear to get the best of me, I made the mistake of teaming up with Dale Knowles, a freshman I'd met at a dorm party. Dale was creating his own major in beat literature. That was the first warning sign. When shaking hands, he tended to position his palm as if he were returning a volleyball. His prominent gums accommodated teeth the size of Chiclets, and he wore a safari hat decorated with buttons and pins promoting everything from the concept of world peace to the legalization of polygamy.
我从未搭车跑过那么远，更别说是一个人了。由于恐惧占了上风，我犯了个错误，和戴尔·诺尔斯结伴而行，一个我在宿舍派对上认识的大一新生。戴尔正在创造属于自己的“垮掉派文学”专业。这就是第一个警告标志。握手时，他总是像在接排球一样摊开手掌。他明显的牙龈露着一排芝麻大小的牙齿，戴着顶装饰着各种徽章的狩猎帽，从呼吁世界和平到合法化一夫多妻制，应有尽有。
What I disliked more than anything else was his laugh, which was prolonged and phlegmy, like a cat tossing up a hairball. And he carried a guitar. We hadn't even gotten our first ride before he pulled it out and began composing one of his appalling ballads. [SINGING] Standing on the highway, thumb up in the air. People passing by, pretending not to care.
我最不喜欢的是他的笑声，拖沓且充满痰音，像只猫在吐毛球。而且他背着一把吉他。我们还没搭上第一辆车，他就掏出吉他开始创作他那令人绝望的民谣。[唱歌] 站在高速路，拇指指向天。人们呼啸过，假装看不见。
I'd sooner pick up someone waving a pistol than holding a guitar. He'd lie barefoot on the side of the road with this head propped up on his knapsack, exercising his toes and wondering why we weren't getting any rides. The guy just didn't get it.
我宁愿搭一个挥着手枪的人，也不要搭一个抱着吉他的人。他会赤脚躺在路边，头枕着背包，动着脚趾头，纳闷为什么没人停下来。这家伙就是不明白。
We were outside of Indianapolis when we were picked up by two young men in a Jeep who introduced themselves as Starsky and Hutch, names borrowed from the brazen, cultish heroes of a popular television show. They were wired and loopy, washing down over-the-counter amphetamines with quarts of malt liquor that rolled back and forth the floorboards beneath the front seat. When asked where they were from, Starsky made a gagging gesture. "That's code for Delaware," Hutch said. Starsky gave the finger to the driver of a boot-shaped Gremlin. "State bird," Hutch said. He took a swallow of his warm malt liquor and belched. "State motto," Starsky said.
我们在印第安纳州郊外被一辆吉普车搭上，两个年轻人自我介绍叫“斯塔斯基”和“哈奇”，名字借用了当时流行美剧里的英雄。他们亢奋且神经质，用烈酒冲服非处方安非他命。问起家乡，斯塔斯基做了个呕吐的姿势。“那是‘特拉华’的代号，”哈奇说。斯塔斯基对着一辆靴子形状的格里姆林轿车司机竖起中指。“州鸟，”哈奇说。他喝了一口温热的烈酒，打了个嗝。“州训，”斯塔斯基说。
Noticing the tank was low, they pulled into a service station, where I offered them some gas money, hoping that, like most people, they might view my generosity as payment enough. Starsky said he had it covered, adding that he could sure use some fudge. "Do you have a taste for it? Well, I do. Run on into the store there and see if they have some." It always made sense for one person to stay with the car in case your driver decided to take off with your pack, so Dale stayed behind, which worked out well for him, seeing as he would rather swallow flashlight batteries than shell out a few dollars for some idiot's fudge.
注意到油表见底，他们开进一个加油站，我主动提出付油钱，希望他们能像大多数人一样，把我的大方当作车费。斯塔斯基说他搞得定，还说他真馋软糖了。“你馋吗？我馋。跑进店里看看有没有。”总要留个人在车上以防司机带行李跑路，所以戴尔留下了，这对他挺好，毕竟他宁愿吞电池也不愿为别人的软糖花钱。
He sat in the backseat while I went into the store and bought a block of something fudge-like and a small bag of potato chips which I might offer as a snack to our next driver. When I got back to the car, Starsky replaced the gas cap and pushed me into the backseat. The attendant headed our way, a roll of bills in his hand, ready to accept payment, and he reached the bumper just as Starsky peeled out of the station, driving over the concrete embankment and onto the interstate.
他坐在后座，我走进店里买了一块像是软糖的东西和一小包薯片，想拿来当零食给下一位司机。回到车里时，斯塔斯基盖好油箱盖把我塞进后座。加油员拿着账单走过来，刚走到保险杠，斯塔斯基就猛地加速，冲上路堤，驶上了州际公路。
"I'm not sure how cool this is," Dale said. "What about the police?" "Police?" Starsky said. "Police? Hey, ho, buddy, we can outrun the damn police, no problem." He stood upon the gas pedal, and the Jeep advanced, much like a plane moments before taking to the air. Starsky had upon his face the expression of a comic book bombardier preparing to destroy a village of unsuspecting peasants. He yelled out for Hutch to hold the wheel he opened the package of fudge, and the Jeep swerved into the other lane, barely missing an oncoming refrigerated truck. Horns blared, and brakes squealed. And for the first time in my life, I thought, this is how people die. This is exactly how it happens.
“我不确定这事儿稳不稳，”戴尔说，“那警察怎么办？”“警察？”斯塔斯基说，“警察？嘿，兄弟，咱们能甩掉那该死的警察，没问题。”他一脚油门到底，吉普车飞速冲刺，就像起飞前的飞机。斯塔斯基脸上的表情就像一名准备摧毁无辜村庄的漫画炸弹手。他让哈奇握紧方向盘，自己拆开软糖包装。吉普车猛冲进另一条车道，差点撞上一辆运冷藏车的货车。喇叭声此起彼伏，刹车声尖利。我平生第一次想到：人就是这样死的，这就是事情发生的经过。
Dale's hat blew out the window, which meant that at least one of us would go with a smile on his face. Had the wind taken his guitar, I might have embraced death with open arms, shouting the word hallelujah and beating a tambourine.
戴尔的帽子被风吹出窗外，这意味着我们至少有一人会带着微笑离开。如果风能带走他的吉他，我可能会张开双臂迎接死亡，高喊哈利路亚并敲起铃鼓。
Starsky and Hutch seemed to enjoy our pathetic displays of fear, jiggling the steering wheel and cutting off other drivers just so they could watch us cower and pray. We covered an enormous amount of ground in an hour before Starsky pulled over to relieve himself behind a billboard, and Dale and I jumped out, hugging our packs. "This is is great," I said. "Really, this is exactly where we wanted to go. Terrific."
斯塔斯基和哈奇似乎很享受我们那种可怜的恐惧表现，他们左右晃动方向盘，切入其他车道，只为了看我们畏缩祈祷的样子。我们在一小时内跑了很远，然后斯塔斯基靠边停车去广告牌后排泄，戴尔和我跳下车，紧紧抱住行李。“这太棒了，”我说，“真的，这就是我们要去的地方，太棒了。”
Dale used the downtime as an opportunity to compose a few new songs.
戴尔趁着这段时间又创作了几首新歌。
[SINGING] I'm well aware they were from Delaware.
[唱歌] 我很清楚，他们来自特拉华。
Days later he was asking for a word that might rhyme with Utah. That'll keep you up all night. I know from experience.
几天后他还在问有什么词能和“犹他”押韵。这事儿能让你整晚睡不着。我是过来人。
We reach San Francisco where Ronnie had gotten me a room at a residence hotel on Market Street. Dale stayed for a week, leaving by bus the day after I walked in on him standing naked before a full length mirror singing [SINGING] "San Francisco, you stole my heart. Now that I found you, I'll never part. California's stirring in my blood."
我们到达旧金山，罗尼在市场街的公寓酒店给我弄了个房间。戴尔待了一周，我那天撞见他赤身裸体站在全身镜前唱着 [唱歌] “旧金山，你偷走了我的心。既然找到你，我永不分离。加州的血液在沸腾。”第二天他就坐巴士走了。
His privates were covered by the guitar, but his pale, spotted rear end was more than I could bear. Ronnie and I stayed on for three months before taking off to pick pears in Oregon. She was the perfect traveling companion, as a boy and girl together have much better luck than two guys. We got rides with single women and truck drivers who claimed they needed company and then never said a word. We slept in abandoned houses and open fields, under bridges and behind barbed-wire fences.
他的私处被吉他挡住了，但他那苍白长斑的屁股让我忍无可忍。罗尼和我待了三个月，然后出发去俄勒冈采梨子。她是完美的旅行同伴，因为男女同行比两个大男人运气好得多。我们搭上了单身女性和自称需要陪伴、全程一言不发的卡车司机的车。我们睡在废弃屋子里、开阔地带、桥下和铁丝网后面。
After the pears were finished, we picked apples and then headed up to Canada, back to California, and across the country, arriving in western North Carolina in mid-November. Ronnie thought she might stay awhile, and I decided to visit a former college roommate in Ohio, the longest trip I'd ever taken alone.
梨子采完后，我们去采苹果，然后北上加拿大，回到加州，横穿全国，在11月中旬抵达北卡罗来纳州西部。罗尼想留在那儿，我决定去俄亥俄州拜访一位大学前室友，那是我独自走过的最长旅程。
I got an interminable ride with a pantyhose salesman who spent six hours saying, "You just take and take, don't you? Don't you? Out there with your thumb in the air, not a care in the world, grabbing whatever you can get. Yes, sir, you take and you take until you're ready to burst. But what about giving? Did you ever think about that? Of course not. You're too busy taking. Me, I'm what you call a taxpayer. Tax, it's a tariff that working people have to pay so that someone like you can enjoy a life of leisure. I give, and I give until I've got nothing left. Then I turn right around, and I give some more. I give and give to all of Uncle Sam's little takers. And I've been thinking that maybe it's about time I get a little something in return. Yes, indeed, maybe it's time we try that shoe on the other foot for a change. You, my young friend, are going to wash my car inside and out, and you're going to pay for it."
我搭上了一辆长得没完没了的连裤袜销售员的车，他花了六小时说：“你只会索取，对吧？对吧？在这儿伸着大拇指，什么都不管，能抓多少抓多少。是的，先生，你索取直到准备爆发。但给予呢？你想过那个吗？当然没有。你太忙于索取了。而我，是所谓的纳税人。税，是劳动人民必须支付的关税，好让像你这样的人享受闲暇生活。我给予，给予，直到一无所有。然后我转过头，又给更多。我给予所有山姆大叔的寄生虫。我一直在想，也许是时候我得到一点回报了。是的，也许是时候换个角度试试了。你，我年轻的朋友，要去帮我把车里里外外洗干净，而且你得自己掏钱。”
He exited the interstate and headed for a car wash, the roof of which supported three cheerful seals buffing a limousine with their motorized fins. The man stood beside the bumper, supervising me as I shampooed and waxed his car. "That's right, put a little muscle into it. Next I want you to empty those ashtrays and vacuum the interior top to bottom. Come on, speedy. Let's get cracking."
他在州际公路出口下去，开往一个洗车场，那屋顶上有三只快乐的海豹正用鳍状肢给豪华轿车抛光。那男人站在保险杠旁，监督着我洗车上蜡。“没错，用点劲。接下来把烟灰缸清空，把车里全吸一遍。快点，小伙子，抓紧。”
I had no problem with the work, but he was driving me out of my mind. "How does it feel to be giving for a change? Not much fun, is it? Hurry up now and buff those hubcaps. Let me see you buff." He had me polish everything from the antenna to the license plate before handing me my pack and driving away.
洗车我没意见，但他简直让我发疯。“这种给予的感觉如何？不太好玩吧？动作快点，把轮毂抛光。让我看看你怎么抛。”他让我把从天线到车牌的一切都擦亮，才把包递给我，开车走了。
I got a ride back to the interstate and another that landed me 20 miles beyond Charleston, West Virginia. It was around 4 o'clock, and I hoped I might catch a long ride that would take me through to Ohio. It was cold, and my hands were chapped from watching that lunatic's car. My fingernails shone from the wax.
我搭车回到州际公路，又搭上一辆车，把我送到了西弗吉尼亚州查尔斯顿以外20英里的地方。大约下午4点，我希望搭上一趟长途车直达俄亥俄。天气很冷，因为洗那个疯子的车，我的手都冻裂了。指甲在蜡光下闪闪发亮。
I waited 10 minutes before someone slowed down and stopped 20 yards up the road. It was a pickup truck advertising an air conditioning and refrigeration company. The man's shirt introduced him as T.W. His fingers were soiled with grease, and the cab of his truck was littered with candy wrappers and soda cans. I asked him what T.W. stood for, and he told me it stood for T.W. and that his last name started with an A, so if you put it all together, it had a nice ring to it. He had an open, sincere face, the features set into a gesture of wonder as if he had spent the last 10 years in a coma, and everything was new and sensational to him.
我等了10分钟，有人减速停在20码外。是一辆喷着空调和制冷公司标志的皮卡车。男人的衬衫上写着他叫T.W.。他的手指沾满油污，驾驶室里到处是糖果纸和汽水罐。我问T.W.是什么意思，他告诉我这就是T.W.，而且他的姓以A开头，连起来读很有韵味。他有一张坦诚的脸，表情仿佛是一个刚从十年植物人状态中醒来，觉得一切都新鲜又刺激的人。
When I told him I was headed to Ohio to study medicine, he said, "Really? Be a doctor and operate? On people? You must be some kind of smart to be a doctor. Operate on brains, you say?" I told him I'd already done it a few times, and it wasn't as hard as it looks. I was hitchhiking because I'd made a bet with a friend that I could get from Duke to Kent State in 18 hours. I didn't need the money. It was just something medical students to blow off steam. "Well, I'll see that you win that bet," T.W. said. He explained that he had cut out of work early and would be happy to take me all the way to Ohio, seeing as he was a night owl. And he hadn't spoken to a doctor since his foot had been crushed by an air conditioner a few years back. "Look at me," he said, brushing the candy wrappers onto the floor, "riding with a brain doctor."
当我告诉他我要去俄亥俄州学医时，他说：“真的吗？做医生还要做手术？给别人做？你一定很聪明才能当医生。你说给大脑做手术？”我告诉他我已经做过几次了，没看起来那么难。我当时在搭便车，因为我和一个朋友打赌说我能在18小时内从杜克大学赶到肯特州立大学。我并不缺钱。这只是医学生消遣的一种方式。“好吧，我会帮你赢下那个赌局的，”T.W.说。他解释说他提前下班了，而且因为他是个夜猫子，很乐意一直送我到俄亥俄州。而且自从几年前他的脚被空调压伤后，他就没再和医生说过话了。“看看我，”他说着，把糖果包装纸扫到地上，“正和一位脑外科医生一起坐车呢。”
We could get started as soon as he dropped some papers off to a friend. That's what he told me. He drove off the interstate and onto a series of highways and country roads before stopping at a tavern. It was a cinder block building lit with signs advertising brands of beer and the existence of a pool table. He asks would I like to come in, but I was under age and had not yet developed a thirst for alcohol.
他送朋友去交点材料，我们就可以出发了。他是这么跟我说的。他开出州际公路，绕过几条高速公路和乡村道路，然后停在一家酒馆前。那是一栋煤渣砖建筑，上面点缀着啤酒品牌和台球桌存在的霓虹灯牌。他问我要不要进去，但我还没到法定饮酒年龄，也还没培养出对酒精的渴求。
It was dusk by this time, the sun fading behind the surrounding mountains. I waited an hour, two hours, three. It had gotten too dark to leave, as I had no idea where I was, and hardly any cars passed along the road. There were no streetlights, and I could hear threatening dogs barking off in the distance. When it began to rain, I took my pack from the bed of the truck and carried it up front, rooting around for an extra sweater and a pair of socks I could wear on my hands.
此时天色已近黄昏，太阳在周围的山峦后渐渐隐去。我等了一个小时、两个小时，又等了三个小时。天色太暗，无法离开了，因为我根本不知道自己在哪里，而且路上几乎没有车经过。那里没有路灯，我能听到远处传来威胁性的狗叫声。当开始下雨时，我从卡车后斗里拿出背包，把它拿到前座，翻找出一件多余的毛衣和一双可以套在手上的袜子。
I stared at the lights of the bar, wondering who might choose to live in such a town. It was pretty enough. You might pass through and admire the mountains, but wouldn't a person then move on to somewhere more important? Travel is supposed to broaden your mind, but it had a way of depressing me. The more places I went, the more people I saw, the more I realized I didn't matter to anyone except the family I'd left behind. And who knew them outside from their friends and neighbors in a town just as pointless as this one? It brought me down to think about it, so I turned on my transistor radio and listened to a local call-in show.
我盯着酒吧的灯光，心想谁会选择住在这样的镇子上。这里的风景确实不错。你路过时可能会欣赏那些山峦，但难道人不会再搬到更重要的地方去吗？旅行本应开阔眼界，但它却让我感到压抑。我去的地方越多，见到的人越多，我就越意识到，除了我抛在身后的家人，我对任何人来说都不重要。而除了那些生活在同样毫无意义的城镇里的朋友和邻居之外，又有谁认识他们呢？想到这些让我情绪低落，于是我打开晶体管收音机，听着当地的听众热线节目。
T.W. staggered out of the bar at around 10 o'clock. He had his arms around a skinny, long-faced man and obese woman who held her pocketbook over her head in protection against the rain. She said something, and the men doubled over laughing. I was in a pretty bad mood, but when you're hitchhiking, it's best to keep it to yourself, as you don't really have a right to complain.
T.W.在10点左右摇摇晃晃地走出酒吧。他搂着一个瘦削、长脸的男人和一个肥胖的女人，那个女人把手提包顶在头上挡雨。她说了句什么，两个男人笑得前仰后合。我当时心情很糟糕，但搭便车时，最好还是别表现出来，因为你其实没有权利抱怨。
Even before he got into the truck, I understood that T.W. was drunk. He waved goodbye to the man and woman and proceeded to start the engine, jabbing the key here and there as though the ignition might have moved during his absence and could be anywhere by now. "Those are my friends," he said. "I've been knowing them all my life, and they're fun people. You got that?" His face had lost that innocent quality and become stern and dogmatic. "Friends," he shouted. "Personal, private friends." He repeated the word several times, pounding his chest with his fist as if he were training an ape to speak. "My friends." Something told me we wouldn't be driving to Ohio anytime soon.
在他上车之前，我就看出T.W.喝醉了。他向那男女挥手告别，然后开始启动引擎，钥匙插来插去，仿佛点火开关在他离开期间移动了，现在不知道在哪儿。“那是我的朋友，”他说。“我认识他们一辈子了，他们都是很有趣的人。明白吗？”他的脸失去了那种纯真，变得严厉而固执。“朋友，”他大喊道。“私人的，私下的朋友。”他重复了几遍这个词，用拳头捶打着胸口，就好像他在教一只猿猴说话一样。“我的朋友。”某种直觉告诉我，我们短时间内是不可能去往俄亥俄州了。
We reached the interstate, and I offered to get out, but he wouldn't hear of it. "You're coming with me," he said. "Home to my house with me. I've got a place fixed up nice with rugs and toasters and a lot of things like that. My house. Mine. No way are you going out on a night like this. Forget all that other crap with school and college. It doesn't matter for stinking squat."
我们到了州际公路上，我提出要下车，但他听都不听。“你得跟我走，”他说。“跟我回家。我把家里布置得很好，有地毯、烤面包机之类的很多东西。我的房子。我的。在这种夜晚，你别想出去。忘了学校和大学那套废话吧。那玩意儿一点屁用都没有。”
I pictured his house as resembling the tavern and hoped it was located on a brightly lit street with a decent amount of traffic. Once there, I could probably make a run for it. "Big brain doctor, are you? Like to stick your fat little fingers in other people's skulls and tinker around? Is that what you like to do? I'll give you plenty to tinker with, hot shot."
我想象着他的家就像那个酒馆一样，希望它位于一条灯火通明、车流量大的街道上。到了那里，我或许能找机会逃跑。“了不起的脑外科医生，是吧？喜欢把胖乎乎的手指插进别人的头盖骨里捣鼓？这就是你喜欢做的事？我会让你捣鼓个够的，小机灵鬼。”
I was looking out at the wet road and didn't see it coming. He grabbed me by the hair and yanked my head down onto the seat, holding me there with one hand while he reached into his jacket pocket with the other. The truck skidded and swerved onto the gravel shoulder before he grabbed the wheel and righted it. The gun felt just the way I always knew it would. He held it against the side of my face, the barrel butting against my jaw.
我正看着潮湿的路面，没看到他接下来的动作。他抓住我的头发，把我的头狠狠地按在座位上，一只手按住我，另一只手伸进夹克口袋。卡车在砂石路肩上滑行晃动，他抓住方向盘矫正了车身。那把枪的手感正如我预想的一样。他把它抵在我脸侧，枪管顶着我的下巴。
I now imagined his home stacked with bodies, as this seemed to be the exact place where something like this might happen. Maybe he'd used his job skills and built a refrigeration chamber to prevent decay. Or maybe he'd bury me beneath some tool shed, and they'd have to identify me through dental records. When had I last been to the dentist? Why wasn't I there now, my mother smoking in the waiting room and copying recipes from the magazines? My dentist would probably say I was asking for it. His dentist would show up on TV, blinking into the camera to testify. "He was such a nice man. We had no idea."
我脑海中浮现出他家里堆满尸体的画面，因为这里看起来正是那种会发生这种事的地方。也许他利用自己的职业技能造了一个冷藏室来防止腐烂。或者他会把我埋在某个工具棚下面，他们还得通过牙科记录来确认我的身份。我最后一次看牙医是什么时候？我为什么现在不待在那儿，我妈在候诊室里抽烟，从杂志上抄食谱呢？我的牙医可能会说是我自找的。他的牙医会出现在电视上，对着镜头眨着眼作证：“他是个很好的人。我们毫无察觉。”
I felt the car slow down and take a turn. We were off the interstate now, probably on an exit ramp. He raised the gun to steady the wheel, and I opened the door and jumped, thinking all the while of the many television detectives who seemed to do this on a weekly basis. "Jump and roll," I told myself. "Jump and roll like Mannix, like Barnaby Jones."
我感觉到车速慢了下来，开始转弯。我们已经离开了州际公路，可能是在出口匝道上。他举起枪稳住方向盘，我打开车门跳了出去，脑海中不断闪过那些每周都会上演这一幕的电视侦探们的身影。“跳出去，滚翻，”我告诉自己。“像曼尼克斯，像巴纳比·琼斯那样跳出去滚翻。”
I hit the gravel shoulder and tumbled into a muddy ditch filled with trash and brambles. My pack had fallen out with me, so I snatched it up and ran. Behind me, I heard the truck pull off the road, the door slam, someone coming through the thicket. I thought I should climb a tree, but that's what you do for bears. No, bears will climb after you, small bears, won't they? But he's not a bear. But still, I can't climb with socks on my hands. He'll only shoot me down or shoot me now in the back maybe, in the head, in the arm, blow my arm off at the shoulder. What I needed was a gun or a knife. The Indians made knives and spears. Even now you'd see them in the souvenir shops. But how did they do it? It took days probably, maybe even weeks. I turned my head to look behind me and fell into a knot of thorny bushes.
我撞在砂石路肩上，滚进了满是垃圾和荆棘的泥沟里。背包和我一起掉了出来，所以我抓起它就跑。身后传来卡车驶离公路的声音，车门重重关上，有人穿过灌木丛追了过来。我想我应该爬树，但那是对付熊的方法。不对，熊也会追着你爬树，小熊也会，对吧？但他不是熊。但我戴着袜子的手根本爬不了树。他要么会把我打下来，要么会从背后、头部、手臂向我开枪，或者把我的整条胳膊轰掉。我需要一把枪或一把刀。印第安人会制造刀子和长矛。即使是现在，你在纪念品店里也能看到。但他们是怎么做的？大概需要几天，甚至几周吧。我转过头看向身后，结果栽进了一丛带刺的灌木里。
I thought to get up and run, but he was too close now. I could see him through the trees, his truck lights shining in the distance. "Idiot," he called. "Hey, you, get back in this truck." He looked off to my right, and I understood that he couldn't see me. "I'm not going to hurt you. Get back here. I was only joking. Hey, you-- hey, it's not even loaded. Look." He pulled the trigger, and the gun made a puny clicking noise. "Come on out. Hey, kid, I swear, I was only joking."
我本想站起来跑，但他已经太近了。透过树木，我能看到他在远处闪烁的卡车灯光。“白痴，”他喊道。“嘿，你，给我回到车里来。”他看向我的右侧，我知道他没发现我。“我不会伤害你的。回来吧。我只是开个玩笑。嘿，你——嘿，它甚至都没上子弹。你看。”他扣动了扳机，枪发出微弱的咔哒声。“出来吧。嘿，小子，我发誓，我只是在开玩笑。”
I watched as he returned to his truck. "Get your ass back here. Hey, dopey, I'm talking to you." He lit a cigarette and tapped on the horn, behaving as though I wanted to come back but had lost the way. He rolled down the window and drove off slowly, the door ajar and the cab lights on, whistling as if for a lost dog.
我看着他回到卡车里。“把你的屁股给我挪回来。嘿，笨蛋，我在跟你说话呢。”他点燃一支烟，按了按喇叭，表现得好像是我自己想回来却迷了路一样。他摇下车窗，慢悠悠地开走了，车门虚掩着，驾驶室的灯亮着，吹着口哨，仿佛在呼唤一只走失的狗。
I waited until I could no longer see the taillights, and then I ran down the exit ramp and into the middle of the interstate, waving my arms and begging someone to stop. The first two cars just missed hitting me, but the third pulled over. Three students headed to Cleveland for an upcoming concert. I told them what had happened, my voice high-pitched and breathy, and the driver turned to me, saying, "Sounds like you're a faggot yourself." This was not the sympathetic reaction I was hoping for.
我等到看不见尾灯后，才跑下匝道，冲进州际公路中间，挥舞着手臂，恳求有人停车。前两辆车险些撞到我，但第三辆车停了下来。那是三个要去克利夫兰参加音乐会的学生。我告诉了他们刚才发生的事，声音尖锐而急促，司机转过头对我说：“听起来你自己就是个娘炮。”这并不是我期待的那种同情回应。
They had picked me up hoping I had some dope, and they were right. We smoked it, and they popped in an 8-track of the Ozark Mountain Daredevils. That was my punishment. My reward was that they never said another word until dropping me off somewhere outside of Akron.
他们载我的时候是希望我身上有毒品，他们猜对了。我们抽了点，他们放了一盘欧扎克山冒险者乐队的八轨磁带。这就是对我的惩罚。而我的奖赏是，他们直到在阿克伦城外某个地方放下我之前，就再也没说过一句话。
I continued to hitchhike for the next few years, but after the incident with T.W., something seemed to have changed. It felt as though I had been marked somehow. I had always counted upon people to trust me, but now I no longer quite trusted them. By this time I was certainly old enough to own my own car but still not weathered enough to appear dangerous. People began picking me up with the idea I had more to offer than my gratitude. Drugs were the easy part. I carried them as a courtesy and offered them whenever asked.
接下来的几年里，我继续搭便车，但在与T.W.的遭遇之后，事情似乎发生了改变。感觉我好像被标记了似的。我一直指望别人会信任我，但现在我不再那么信任他们了。那时我已经成年，完全有能力拥有自己的车，但还没老练到让人觉得危险。人们开始载我，是因为他们觉得我能提供的不仅仅是感激。毒品是简单的那部分。我带着它们以示礼貌，只要有人问，我就给他们。
It was the sexual advances that got to me. I had never been much to look at, but that never seemed to matter, as neither were they. When I though of sex, I pictured someone standing before me crying, "I love you so much that I don't even know who I am anymore." He was no particular age or race. All that mattered is that he was crazy about me. This thing with drivers wasn't what I had in mind at all. I got the idea they were married with children. "You fool around much when hitchhike?" they'd ask, the question always fast like that and always phrasing it in such a way that they could follow it up with, "I'm only kidding. Jeez. What's your problem?"
真正让我受不了的是那些性骚扰。我的长相一直很普通，但那似乎并不重要，因为他们也一样。当我想起性时，我脑海中浮现出有人站在我面前哭着说：“我如此爱你，以至于我甚至不知道自己是谁了。”他不分年龄或种族。唯一重要的是他为我疯狂。而司机们的这些事根本不是我想要的。我感觉他们都是有家室、有孩子的人。“你搭车的时候常玩吗？”他们会这样问，问题总是很快，而且措辞方式总是让他们可以接着说：“我只是开玩笑。天哪。你有什么毛病？”
I studied myself in the mirror, trying to figure out what had changed, but all I saw was the same old me, wanting to be someone else. I had an unpleasant experience with a married couple outside of Atlanta, a middle-aged man and woman driving a Cadillac nude at 2:00 AM. A few days later in Fayetteville, I was led down a dark dirt road by a man who promised to crush my skull like a peanut. The second time you find yourself cowering in the bushes, you know it's time to ask yourself some tough questions. I got on a bus and never hitchhiked again. To this day, I still haven't learned to drive a car. It seems much too dangerous, and besides that, I'm just not the type to fill out insurance forms. I moved to cities with decent public transportation systems, Chicago and then New York, which is even better. You hold out your hand for a ride but fold the thumb and pinky against your palm. The drivers don't speak English, which comes as a relief. You have to pay, but then again, you always do.
我在镜子里审视自己，试图找出哪里变了，但我看到的还是那个老样子的我，渴望成为别人。我在亚特兰大郊外有过一次不愉快的经历，一对中年夫妇在凌晨两点开着凯迪拉克裸奔。几天后在费耶特维尔，一个男人把我引到一条黑暗的泥路上，威胁说要把我的头骨像花生一样捏碎。第二次当你发现自己躲在灌木丛中瑟瑟发抖时，你就知道该问自己一些严肃的问题了。我坐上公交车，再也没有搭过便车。直到今天，我还没学会开车。这看起来太危险了，再说，我也不是那种会去填保险单的人。我搬到了有完善公共交通系统的城市，先是芝加哥，然后是纽约，那里更好。你伸出手拦车，但要收起拇指和小指。司机们不会说英语，这反而让人松了口气。虽然要付钱，但话说回来，干什么不需要付钱呢。
Every so often, I'll find myself in a car driven by a friend, and we'll pass someone by the side of the road. He's young, and the force of traffic has disheveled his hair. He looks into your eyes, pretending to expect nothing, and his lips are moving, practicing the story he plans to tell. "Pull over," I say. "I think I know that person."
每隔一段时间，当我坐在一辆由朋友驾驶的车里时，我们经过路边的一个人。他很年轻，车流带来的风吹乱了他的头发。他看着你的眼睛，假装什么都不求，嘴唇在动，练习着他打算讲述的故事。“靠边停一下，”我说。“我想我认识那个人。”
David Sedaris is the author of Barrel Fever and the forthcoming book Naked. And I know what you're thinking. Every time you turn on the public radio, it's the Ozark Mountain Daredevils.
大卫·塞达里斯是《木桶热》和即将出版的新书《赤裸》的作者。我知道你在想什么。每次你打开公共电台，都能听到欧扎克山冒险者乐队的歌。
[MUSIC - "IF YOU WANNA GET TO HEAVEN" BY OZARK MOUNTAIN DAREDEVILS]
[音乐 - 欧扎克山冒险者乐队演唱的《如果你想去天堂》]
Yeah, whatever that means.
是的，不管那意味着什么。
Our program was produced today but Peter Clowney, Alix Spiegel, Nancy Updike, and myself. Contributing editors Paul Tough, Jack Hitt, and Margy Rochlin. Some songs today were provided by Steve Cushing and the Blues Before Sunrise radio network. But not this one.
今天的节目由彼得·克劳尼、阿利克斯·斯皮格尔、南希·厄普代克和我制作。特约编辑保罗·塔夫、杰克·希特和玛吉·罗克林。今天的一些歌曲由史蒂夫·库欣和“日出前的蓝调”广播网提供。但这首不是。
If you would like a copy of this radio program, it's only $10. You can call us at WBEZ in Chicago to get it. 312-832-3380 is the number. 312-832-3380. Our email address, [email protected] .
如果您想要一份本广播节目的副本，只需10美元。您可以致电芝加哥的WBEZ获取。号码是312-832-3380。312-832-3380。我们的电子邮箱是 [email protected] 。
[FUNDING CREDITS]
[资助名单]
WBEZ management oversight by Torey Malatia. I'm Ira Glass.
WBEZ管理监督由托里·马拉蒂亚负责。我是艾拉·格拉斯。
What will he find out there in the forbidden zone, Dr. Zaius? Damn you! Damn you all to hell!
他在禁区里会发现什么，扎伊尔斯博士？去你的！通通下地狱去吧！
Back next week with more stories of This American Life.
下周回来，继续带来更多关于“美国生活”的故事。